on shankle road in belfast they are
mourning their queen and the loss is
palpable she was a wonderful woman
she really was
i don't think there'd be another
monarch like her
i don't honestly
here in the loyalist heartland they're
proud to call themselves british
she was my commander-in-chief
she was my boss
for 22 years
um best boss in the world
you've never felt available
on the opposite side of the wall there's
no great outpouring of grief on the
republican folds road this british queen
we're irish but it didn't hit her
anything uh
sorry for her loss and sorry for her
family that's everybody's to the room
but it's not something i would you know
she was a mother she was a grandmother
but it's just not you know so sad on the
family
northern ireland has a nationalist first
minister designate sinn fein's michelle
o'neill said this wasn't the time for
anti-monarchy sentiment this is a time
for everybody to be respectful
um queen elizabeth has died there's a
family that is mourning her loss at the
end of the day she may have been the
queen of england but she was also a
mother and a grandmother and i think
people should be very respectful this is
a time for reflection this is the time
to be
respectful of all people and how they
feel right now
this tight security at the royal
residence in northern ireland it didn't
stop people coming to reflect at
hillsborough castle
she'll be surely miss
everybody
it doesn't matter what religion whoever
you're from what color you are that i
think the millions of people around the
world it's the same state as me today
northern ireland is the corner of the
united kingdom where you'll find the
most loyal subjects of the crown and the
least loyal but even in this divided
society where some are not fans of the
monarchy there is broad consensus that
queen elizabeth herself personally made
an enormous contribution to the search
for peace
the queen led the way on reconciliation
her legacy challenges a new generation
to make the same pledge for peace
david blevins sky news in belfast